[Musica]
nel 1981 cliff orsi ma uno scrittore di
fantascienza americana pubblica un
romanzo intitolato il papa definitivo
siamo in un mondo in cui il robot sono
diventati particolarmente raffinati anzi
sono capaci di gestirsi ormai da soli e
sono anche capace di ripararsi non
muoiono più non si rompono più scoprono
di essere immortali e il robot è
immortale si interroga adesso cosa
faccio anche perché gli uomini è vero
che sono o non sono immortali ma loro
loro c'hanno l'anima
noi no questa cosa ma da in crisi il
robot a tal punto che vanno su un
pianeta lontano dalla terra e dicono
anche noi vogliamo come gli uomini
la religione che è la cosa che serve per
gestire la nostra immortalità e
costruiscono un nuovo vaticano con tutti
i robot vestiti da cardinali e intorno
ai cardinali il papa definiti e il papa
è infallibile
e allora il robot producono una realtà
infallibile un sistema di conoscenza che
raccoglie tutti i dati del mondo e
sapendo tutto giustamente è infallibile
eh sì se questa cosa interesse agli
uomini interessa anche al vero botto
ora che c'entra tutto questo
e questo anche il libro di fantascienza
e c'è il fatto che io lavoro in vaticano
e mi occupo di robot o io non sono come
capita ogni tanto il mega esperto di una
materia che ha insegnato o tecnologie ed
è capace di ha fatto le cose più
incredibili poi un certo punto alle
visioni clamorose cambia aveva in un
monastero a finire i suoi giorni noi
lo prete normale quello che ha studiato
la teologia studiato un po più di
filosofia si è occupato dei catechesi
dei ragazzi ha scritto anche qualche
libro di cucina una persona normale ma
lavoro alla pontificia accademia per la
vita
160 grandi scienziati di tutto il mondo
provenienti da diverse culture
tradizioni religioni che intuiscono che
il loro lavoro scientifico può essere a
servizio della vita umana
loro si sono gli esperti e loro si sono
si radunano e si ritrovano ea un certo
punto hanno detto attenzione dobbiamo
riflettere sull'interazione tra le nuove
tecnologie e la vita degli uomini e non
solo dobbiamo riflettere non solo
dobbiamo comprendere maggiormente e
studiarle no attenzione forse dobbiamo
fare anche un passo in più dobbiamo
intuire quali sono le scelte che ci
permettano di porre anche questa
incredibile nuova tecnologia a servizio
degli uomini e delle donne e dobbiamo
coinvolgere chi queste cose le
costruisce tutti i giorni e così abbiamo
lavorato abbiamo lavorato per diversi
mesi e alla fine un anno e mezzo fa
abbiamo costruito un testo la rom col
fare ai etics un testo solletica
dell'intelligenza artificiale e abbiamo
detto chi vuole firmarla chi ci sta a
costruirla e roma sono venuti e brad
smith presidente di microsoft è venuto
john kelly il vice presidenti di a e b m
è venuto il direttore generale della fao
ci è venuto un ministro di una
repubblica è venuto presidente della del
del parlamento europeo
a firmarlo a dire ma questa cosa
importante ci teniamo lo facciamo
ecco il mio lavoro è stato metterli
attorno a questo tavolo permettere che
accadesse questo incontro è e si
arrivasse a una ferma e così io mi siedo
con loro a questo tavolo e ascolto e
imparo e the soft voi sapete cosa sono
le block chain
ecco all'inizio quando parlava di questa
roba naturalmente a nuovo ma non perché
era un esperto di block chain
praticamente non sapevo quasi nulla
le block chain sono un sistema di
codificazione di dati attraverso delle
catene che man mano si bloccano ogni
volta che io scrivo una cosa una
crittografia la blocca e la rende
definitiva per sempre la catena può
allungarsi può aggiungerci sempre dei
dei pezzetti ma non può mai essere
cambiata nel passato quello che è
scritto e registrato una volta lo è per
sempre
ora non è che adesso sia un esperto di
boccette però ho intuito qualcosa di più
e le parole capite catena blocco
immutabilità incancellabili ta
definitività e interessante in un tempo
che è definito quello della società
liquida in un tempo in cui non
rifiutiamo ogni dogma e ogni assoluto
nel tempo dello sforamento del blogging
nel tempo in cui desideriamo sopra ogni
altra cosa essere liberi anche ogni
giorno di ridisegnare completamente la
nostra vita e di poter prendere
qualunque scelta
noi produciamo un sistema tecnologico
che ci offre certezze stabilità
immutabilità come mai uno dei frutti più
moderni della nostra tecnologia è in
realtà così anti moderno
ora questa cosa funziona perché abbiamo
imparato a fare una cosa cioè abbiamo
trovato un linguaggio comune per tutto
alla fine la digitalizzazione che cos'è
se non la possibilità di dire con un
unico linguaggio ogni cosa le immagini
le parole i dati i processi una serie
infinita di 0 11 00 01 acceso spento
spento spento acceso agello svento
addirittura adesso stanno lavorando per
digitalizzare cioè per
vendere dentro questo messaggio anche ai
nostri processi mentali forse anche
quelli affettivi
quello che non erano riusciti a fare i
costruttori della torre di babele avete
in mente quella che crolla per un
linguaggio unico oppure gli uomini che
hanno inventato l'esperanto questo
tentativo di un linguaggio globale una
cosa complicatissima lo hanno fatto gli
informatici mettendo uno dopo l'altro
un'infinita serie di zero e di uno ci
hanno regalato uno dei sogni che avevamo
un linguaggio comune e noi ci siamo
illusi
la legge di moore è una legge che è
stata costruita all'inizio del durante
lo sviluppo dell'informatica e serve a
stabilire la capacità di sviluppo della
potenza di calcolo delle macchine
informati nei computer ce la siamo
bellamente bevuta
noi oggi abbiamo delle macchine così
potenti che neanche lontanamente
possiamo immaginare ora capite che un
linguaggio comune e una macchina
clamorosamente potente che ci permettono
di dire ogni cosa arriviamo quasi a dire
che noi possiamo conoscere tutto e
questa cosa ci piace e come quando siamo
nel lotto alla fine dell'ottocento dopo
la rivoluzione industriale e abbiamo
questo grande ottimismo nella scienza e
nella tecnologia sono che in realtà noi
viviamo
dopo heisenberg heisenberg era un filo
in fisico vissuto all'inizio del
novecento è famoso perché produce un
principio per cui dice che noi non
possiamo conoscere la totalità del reale
ci sfugge sempre qualcosa a noi non
piace vivere dopo heisenberg ci piace
più di vivere pensando che possiamo
conoscere tutto che possiamo dire tutto
con un unico linguaggio e la tecnologia
digitale ci sostiene in questo orgoglio
in questo desiderio in questa bramosia
di conoscere tutto
in realtà c'è una cosa che ci interessa
ancora di più
più ancora del sapere tutto ci piace
sapere come sarà il nostro futuro
questa cosa ci prende ci preoccupa ci
assilla ci appassiona saremmo disposti a
fare qualunque cosa pur di conoscere il
nostro futuro e del futuro delle persone
che i nostri figli delle persone a cui
vogliamo bene
l'anno scorso abbiamo steso 8 miliardi
di euro in italia per oroscopi e maghi
per sapere il futuro ma in questo
abbiamo la nuova tecnologia perché la
capacità di dati l'immensità dei dati la
capacità delle macchine degli algoritmi
sempre più raffinati hanno fatto sì che
possediamo una tecnologia capace di
essere predittiva di capire come uno si
comporterà
e cosa accadrà e ci indovina chi
indovina più di noi e del mago otelma ci
indovina funziona ma forse qualcuno
pensava che fosse un caso che la più
grande società una delle più grandi
società di gestione dei dati e forse la
più famosa si chiama oracle oracolo come
adelphi 2.800 anni fa dove si andava per
sapere il futuro
torniamo ai nostri robot perché quasi
sempre li costruiamo con delle fattezze
umane e perché sempre lì raffiguriamo
con fattezze umane o perché noi
utilizziamo delle parole tipicamente
umane per parlare di processi
tecnologici tipo l'intelligenza appunto
artificiale è che quando noi facciamo le
cose costruiamo le cose e raggiungiamo
anche dei livelli molto alti nella
progettazione
noi ci abbiamo sempre in mente noi è
come se fossimo perennemente allo
specchio
l'uomo noi con le domande su chi siamo
che forma abbiamo cosa significa essere
intelligenti e quando ancora ci
riflettiamo sulle intelligenza di una
macchina in realtà per il solo fatto che
usiamo quella parola lì stiamo ora
paragone la stiamo paragonando a noi le
nuove tecnologie
in realtà sembrano essere abbastanza
vecchie si ripongono le questioni di
sempre con due conseguenze la prima è
che di fatto noi viviamo ossessionati
dalla tecnologia siamo disposti a
qualunque cosa pur di comprare l'oggetto
ultimo uscito più di avere la lap più
perfetta perché abbiamo perché siamo
certi che questa cosa ci aiuterà a fare
meglio le cose ci aiuterà a vivere
meglio ci permetterà di fare delle cose
che prima neanche lontanamente
immaginavamo ci permette di essere più
performativi più efficaci e più
efficienti e quindi la prendiamo nel
gli uomini hanno speso un triliardo di
dollari divertitevi a mettere tutti gli
zeri necessari un triliardo di dollari
per comperare nuova tecnologia ci piace
è una cosa che ci ubriaca anche in senso
concreto
e ai 0 five è un whisky svedese un blend
un mix di whisky che è stato prodotto
con un sistema di intelligenza
artificiale e c'è anche un profumo egeo
fatto così con l'intelligenza
artificiale e naturalmente la pubblicità
l'ha presentata esattamente questo non
perché questo whisky e particolarmente
buono ma perché fatto con l'intelligenza
artificiale appunto ci piace è la cosa
migliore al mondo
e così noi certamente non lo diciamo
apposta non lo diciamo non lo ammettiamo
ma questa cosa ce l'abbiamo nella testa
noi iniziamo a pensare che il digitale
sia la questione decisiva sia il tema
del nostro tempo sia ciò che dobbiamo
mettere al centro e qui intervengono le
lavatrici gli esperti racconto dicono
che anche i migliori sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale in realtà fanno
esattamente come le lavatrici certo in
una maniera estremamente più raffinata e
in modo che ancora noi facciamo fatica a
conoscere come sempre accade davanti a
una grossa innovazione digitale che
cambia la nostra vita cioè obbediscono
agli ordini fanno quello che gli diciamo
di fare ora quando avete preso a calci
la vostra lavatrice perché via
infeltrito il vostro maglione più bello
in realtà io credo nessuno di voi avesse
in mente di dire è colpa tua
in realtà il calcio ce lo stavamo un po
dando tradimento quanto sono scemo avere
fatto questa cosa
ora visto che giustamente non incolpiamo
la nostra lavatrice di questa colpa
perché invece ci poniamo questa domanda
riguardo a queste nuove macchine che
guidano da soli
il tema della responsabilità di una
macchina che guida a guida autonoma è
uno dei classici del dibattito sulla
riflessione della responsabilità e
dell'etica oggi è che queste tecnologie
sono così potenti costituzione sono così
human friendly così simili a noi si
integrano con noi clamorosamente così
bene a tal punto che quasi ce l'abbiamo
talvolta le abbiamo anche dentro le
nostre orecchie nei nostri occhi prima o
poi ce la metteranno nel nostro cervello
che iniziamo a pensare che che siano
forse loro i responsabili della delle
scelte po come noi questo è un passaggio
pericoloso e soprattutto è un passaggio
che gli esempi che hanno dimostrati
abbiamo fatto fino adesso
in realtà dice il contrario le nuove
tecnologie non fanno che nient'altro che
riportare al centro e alla
responsabilità delle scelte
gli uomini gli woman center artificial
intelligence è un tema classico
intelligenza artificiale centrata su
l'uomo è una questione che sta offrendo
cioè su cui sta lavorando in molti molti
centri si intitolano così forse oggi noi
dobbiamo assumerci la responsabilità di
una tecnologia digitale che mette al
centro l'uomo e questo vale anche per la
pratica di gita per la pratica
democratica
nell'epoca digitale perché non basta
potere sfruttare al massimo le infinite
potenzialità di questa tecnologia per
permettere davvero a ognuno di poter
partecipare al dibattito democratico e
insieme non basta neanche essere del
tutto avvertiti e seriamente preoccupati
delle infinite per delle molte
pericolosità che tecnologie così
efficienti e pervasive anno no la
questione è oltre ancora il digitale
questa cosa così nuova e così vecchia in
realtà non fa nient'altro che ridire
guarda che al centro c'è l'uomo una
democrazia digitale in quanto digitale
non fa nient'altro che riporre al centro
l'uomo
e le sue domande le domande di certezza
di sicurezza di un linguaggio comune di
una responsabilità presa di un futuro
migliore
una democrazia digitale è una democrazia
che mette al centro l'uomo
o meglio le donne e gli uomini i piccoli
ei grandi di forti e i deboli i buoni
anche i cattivi questo plurale così
complicato fastidioso ma ineludibile
questa cosa che la cosa più preziosa che
abbiamo le loro storie i loro volti